y hace 160 millones de años surgió un
bosque en lo que más tarde sería llamado
chillán en la familia upl y son la
jornada escolar empieza en la sala
leticia y su cónyuge eligieron la
educación en familia la uif para sus
cuatro hijos una pequeña media hora de
historia del mundo acompañada de
proyectos educativos programación
informática taller de costura origami en
esta casa los niños eligen ellos mismos
sus actividades de manera autónoma pero
con seguimiento de lesionados lo que
establecemos es nuestra manera de vivir
no contamos con un programa que debe
culminar en algún momento del año tal
vez hagamos mucho de algo y poco de otra
cosa
una ausencia de programa que no impide
la adquisición de competencias
controladas por la educación nacional
hoy por primera vez en el año
moira malik y aloha van a la escuela al
colegio
michel vigón en blog entonces lo debemos
cambiar mucho con respecto al año pasado
cierto
no mucho durante las tres horas de
entrevista el equipo tres inspectores y
un psicólogo hablan con leticia y sus
hijos temas lecturas aprendizaje y
orientación el objetivo de los
inspectores lograr discernir los avances
de los tres niños en edad de estar en la
escuela queremos ver en qué nivel está
el niño si avanza si está haciendo todo
para que evolucione vemos su grafía no
era un ejercicio era para ver cómo se
expresaban y ver si la escritura
concuerda
estas familias están siendo vigiladas
por el ejecutivo la ley sobre el respeto
de los principios de la república antes
llamada ley sobre el separatismo
pretendía prohibir la educación en
familia según el gobierno la escuela a
domicilio les habría permitido a las
familias sustraerse a principios
nacionales como la laicidad una amalgama
con las escuelas clandestinas para las
familias implicadas
los niños instruidos en casa son
pequeños fantasmas de la repubblica o
peligrosos separatistas e incluso como
lo dijo el ministro de educación
salvajes
el discurso de jean michel blanc e hirió
a esta familia en la que la madre eligió
volverse profesora quién es la persona
indicada para elegir lo que es mejor
para sus hijos sobre los que los aman y
los que viven con ella lo siento pero el
señor macro manolín cada vez son mis
hijos no los conoce y no los ve todos
los días de canepa conoce son
estudiantes de paraná en el senado en el
que la derecha es mayoritaria una
enmienda en comisión acaba de eliminar
el artículo 21 que instauraba
condiciones para la enseñanza a
domicilio para max brisson senador
republicano y miembro de la comisión
cultura y educación este artículo
contravenía una libertad constitucional
y se equivocaba de blanco desde juniper
y la obligación de la educación es o la
escuela pública o la escuela privada o
la enseñanza a domicilio la libertad de
enseñar es una libertad constitucional
yo creo que esta ley es una ley de
emociones que permite al ministro
mostrar su músculo le vendría bien
el fuego es el poder ejecutivo el que
debería aplicar las leyes que ya existen
y la puntilla de la enseñanza en familia
concierne el 0.5 por ciento del total de
los alumnos en francia una minoría en la
que los casos de radicalización siguen
siendo excepcionales según el ministerio
de educación una cifra muy baja para
sacar un estudio sociológico
la situación es que los controladores de
la educación nacional encuentran son
excepcionales
y sería muy incómodo decir que tal medio
situación son familias radicalizadas
es muy excepcional para hablar de esta
manera el modo de router situación no
puede detectar a si queréis ese tipo de
excepciones por su bajo total esta peña
una modalidad de enseñanza alternativa
que gana adeptos desde hace unos 10 años
la familia aplistone recibe hoy en día a
otra familia que acaba de iniciar con la
educación a domicilio perrine gaité
profesora retirada dio el paso
convencida por el sistema de solidaridad
es importante para nosotros los padres y
para los niños para que puedan ser
felices entonces se trata de
invitaciones actividades compartidas
como la piscina cuando se podía los
senadores se pronunciaron en contra de
la puesta en marcha de criterios para la
educación a domicilio el ministerio de
educación insiste cada niño tendrá que
recibir un número de identificación
nacional obligatorio la educación
nacional estima en cinco mil la cantidad
de niños de los que se ignora la
modalidad de instrucción tanto en
escuela como en familia